puis avec nous également fabrice grimal
qui est candidat citoyens l'élection
présidentielle bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
d'abord jean paul stahl un troisième à
samedi deux manifestations contre
l'extension du planétaire en france
votre regard sur ces mobilisations
j'ai eu du losc totalement ubuesque et
les hommes politiques et femmes
politiques qu'ils sont en soutien de
tout ça sont totalement irresponsables
c'est tout qu'elle est qu'elle est là en
plus de véhiculer des informations
fausses
j'ai entendu de vous interviewez qui
disait qu'on avait refusé l'entrée des
malades à l'hôpital
je veux dire c'est ça vient de la
planète mars
cette histoire là ça n'existe pas donc
je pense que tout le monde a perdu de
harrington de vue enfin en tout cas ces
personnes là ont perdu de vue l'objectif
l'objectif c'est pas d'embêter la
population française l'objectif c'est de
mettre fin à une épidémie pour que tout
le monde puisse retrouver une vie
normale
alors ok on discute on sur les moyens de
le faire mais quelles sont les solutions
alternatives à la vaccination jean paul
stahl s'agissant du pas de sanitaires
exigé à l'entrée des hôpitaux
c'est une mesure bien effective enquête
concernant les malades les moins urgents
les moins urgents non ça ne concerne pas
les malades ça ne concerne pas les
malades jamais aucun malade n'a été
refusée il ne sera refusé
dans un hôpital français ça ça n'existe
pas le pass sanitaire est demandée pour
les accompagnants pour éviter de mettre
les malades en danger
ça c'est ça c'est vrai mais par contre
exiger un passani terre pour un malade
qui rentre à l'hôpital
évidemment ça n'existe pas par contre
pour des raisons de diagnostic de
sécurité des patients on peut leur faire
un test de dépistage
c'est pas parce sanitaires
c'est un honneur une démarche
diagnostique une démarche médicale qu'il
y ait ou non une loi sur le pass
sanitaires ça n'a absolument rien à voir
c'est là tout le bon mélange tout
fabrice vial quoi fabrice grimal
ubuesque selon jean paul steijns ce
troisième samedi de mobilisation anti
passe votre avis là-dessus je trouve pas
ça du tout lui est ce que monsieur stage
se saisit quelques arguments mais en
oubliant tous les autres et si on perd
notre émission et quelques minutes qui
ont précédé on a entendu beaucoup
beaucoup d'arguments et je ne sais pas
si monsieur ce talent pour répondre à
tous moi on se base aussi sur notre
expérience personnelle nos relations nos
amis et moi j'ai rencontré quelqu'un qui
a reçu une lettre de son hôpital et qui
lui demandait un pass sanitaires pour
accéder à sa une radiothérapie dans le
dans le cadre d'un cancer donc oui oui
ces choses là existe effectivement il ya
peut-être d'autres manières de traiter
cette ducobu monsieur stahl ferait bien
de prendre en compte le fait que quand
un gouvernement raconte tout et son
contraire ment et part dans des
directives absurde depuis un an et demi
surtout avec des résultats médiocres
puisque le gouvernement devrait dresser
le bilan de son action depuis un an et
demi s'il n'est pas capable de faire on
peut le faire pour lui le nombre de
vagues 3e 4e
le nombre de morts dus qu'aux vide ou
d'autre chose puisque le confinement qui
s'est révélée largement inutile pour
combattre l'épidémie s'est révélée par
contre horrible pour ce qui concerne par
exemple les jeunes ou pour certains
certaines personnes âgées qui sont
décédés allait pas sans accompagnement
sans pouvoir revoir leurs proches
ça fait ça a généré d'un prêt millions
de dt dépression nerveuse des suicides
d'étudiants c'est quand même dingue
comprennent jamais ça en pose là
aujourd'hui
monsieur stèle nous explique le but du
gouvernement est de soigner
moi c'est pas du tout l'impression que
j'ai je pense que le but du gouvernement
est de diviser la population qui a des
raisons électoralistes derrière qu
emmanuel macron cimente sa base et se
fiche complètement du fait que le reste
de la population le déteste
moi je reviens de la manifestation de
bordeaux aujourd'hui puisque je je fais
une réunion publique demain à 14 heures
à marcheprime
j'ai vu des j'ai vu des français j'ai vu
évidemment des gilets jaunes mais pas
que beaucoup de primo manifestants qui
ont rejoint ce mouvement pour protester
contre une atteinte gravissime à leur
liberté dans ce pays
justement c'est fabrice climat cette
contestation elle elle a lieu dans toute
la france aujourd'hui à paris iv
manifestation est en ce moment même il
ya une dispersion qui se déroule sous
tension place de la bastille les forces
de l'anp qui font usage de gaz
lacrymogène on a vu les images et deux
canons à eau
donc pour disperser les manifestants
vous voyez cette place de la bastille
3000 av policiers qui sont déployés
aujourd'hui dans la capitale poursuivre
c'est quatre cortèges
voilà la situation place de la bastille
moment où l'on se parle jean paul stahl
justement est ce que quand même on peut
comprendre vu les profils des
manifestants anti passe il ya des gilet
jaune
il ya des des manifestants c'est qu'ils
brandissent des camps des pancartes
contre le président emmanuel macron est
ce qu'on peut comprendre aussi qu'il ya
beaucoup d'interrogations chez tous ces
manifestants concernant les mesures de
restrictions qui sont mises en place
aujourd'hui ça concerne évidemment la
vaccination mais pas seulement puisque
il ya des mesures aussi en outre-mer en
lois qui font l'objet de beaucoup
d'interrogations et de contestation je
veux pas faire de commentaires
politiques parce que je ne suis pas un
homme politique et je veux pas faire de
commentaires sociologique parce que je
ne suis pas sociologue
par contre médicalement l'afer est
extrêmement simple en termes de mesures
à prendre
il s'agit d'un virus qui est hébergé par
des individus porteurs qui peuvent le
transmettre à des individus récepteur
alors après il faut qu'on m'explique
comment on fait pour éviter que ce
mécanisme se met en place
est ce que on fait comme avant et voilà
rien n'existe et à ce moment là on
espère on a ce qui est arrivé au brésil
avec un demi million de morts est-ce
qu'on veut ça si on ne veut pas ça eh
bien il ya obligatoirement des mesures
de restriction c'est obligé
il n'y a pas d'autre façon de faire et
ça c'est quelque chose peut même
médecine connaît depuis l'antiquité
c'est à dire l'isolément des patients
contagieux ça n'est rien d'autre que ça
alors que d'après certains profitent de
2,2 je dirais d'une inquiétude ou de la
possibilité de manipulations pour des
raisons politiques ça les regarde mais
moi d'un point de vue médical je trouve
ça criminel parce que derrière il ya des
morts alors jean postale juste un point
justement sur l'évolution du nouveau
variant delta et les inquiétudes autour
de sa propagation
pour l'instant on a dépassé le seuil des
50% de la population entièrement
vacciner c'est un seuil dépassé mardi
soir mais on est loin encore de
desseilles d'immunité collective qui est
évalué à 90 % avec le variant delta donc
à de réelles raisons de s'inquiéter
en métropole il ya de réelles raisons de
s'inquiéter et qu'à regarder ce qui se
passe dans les territoires ultramarins
est-ce qu'on veut leur confinement parce
qu'ils sont obligés de faire ça il n'y a
pas d'autre solution
y'en a pas d'autre qu'à partir du moment
où vous n'êtes pas vacciné
donc est-ce qu'on veut ça ou bien est ce
que on veut en terminer avec ces crises
et ça passe obligatoirement y a pas
autre chose ça passe obligatoirement par
la vaccination est d'autant plus que le
virus circulants il peut muter ça c'est
le propre d'un virus et plus il ya de
virus qui circule maps et les risques
que surgisse un invariant qui serait
moins sensibles à la vaccination plus
les risques sont importants
donc il ya un enjeu à la fois de
protection des individus qui sont
vaccinées je rappelle simplement que
j'étais dans d'autres services
ce matin il à 98% des personnes qui sont
hospitalisées et le nom est en train
d'augmenter sont des gens qui ne sont
pas vaccinés ou mal vaccinés pour de
multiples raisons
c'est on a donc en ce moment une
épidémie qui se développent chez les non
vaccinés
est-ce qu'on veut ça et d'autre part les
personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés
contribuer à la main la circulation du
virus et donc au risque d'un variant qui
résisterait aux au vaccin est donc un
danger délai pour ceux qui sont
vaccinées donc il ya un problème de
responsabilité collective qui est
absolument indispensable absolument
indispensable et je le redis quand on
appelle à se mobiliser contre ce type de
raisonnement médical mais on n'est pas
responsable
on est il responsable fabrice gaiman
florian philippot qui a mené 5 a appelé
une nouvelle fois donc à se rassembler
contre le pass sanitaire vous partager
son avis vous quelle est votre
appréciation de son initiative il n'est
pas le seul à avoir ce type d'initiative
beaucoup appellent à manifester le
samedi moi le premier un certain nombre
d'os dans toutes les villes de france se
trouve que lui pas revendiquer une
certaine antériorité chez les ch et les
politiques installé ce qui passe
régulièrement dans les grands médias
c'est vrai qu'il est un des seuls à
avoir à avoir lancé sa le samedi donc
ylang-ylang récolte les fruits
aujourd'hui
ça veut pas dire qu'il va en faire
quelque chose d'utile pour pour notre
pays mais en tous les cas voilà on
aimerait que la classe politique
française se mobilise et étienne
peut-être un autre discours que ce qu'on
entend actuellement je voudrais revenir
sur ce que disait monsieur ce talent qui
qui parle en théorie et en théorie on
aimerait tous y vivre en théorie parce
que ce tout s'y passe bien mais c'est
pas le cas
parle comme si c'était une maladie
connue qui avait 50 ans avec un vaccin
très enfin qualifié validé et rendu
obligatoire de ce fait comme par exemple
pour la polio pour le tétanos c'est pas
du tout le cas l'efficacité du vaccin
reste à approuver surtout sûr sûr sûr
les variants oui nous donne des chiffres
pour son sens l'hôpital je les conteste
pas il se trouve que nous on a des
chiffres pour d'autres hôpitaux qui
donnent une majorité de personnes
vaccinées a mis ce qui qui contractent
le vide c'est le cas par exemple parce
que c'est toujours plus facile de parler
de personnes connues du d'inde et
chanteur de kassav qui est décédé
aujourd'hui après trois doses de vaccin
donc on peut dire qu'il avait des
comorbidités nous mais on peut un peu à
chaque fois sortir des prétextes de
chaque cas est particulier
il n'empêche que à large échelle ce
vaccin pose des questions et je m'arrête
là je me rende pas dans les détails pour
ne pas affoler monsieur ce talent mais
ce vaccin pause à tout le moins des
questions
et effectivement si on parle en
scientifique et non pas en politique on
doit reconnaître ce fait et ensuite
comprendre tout simplement qu' un
gouvernement qui est décrédibilisé
depuis longtemps sur un certain nombre
d'autres sujets paqueta que celui là qui
en plus s'est décrédibilisé sur le co
vie parce que si on reprend les
déclarations de madame busan de monsieur
vers ans le nombre de volte face le
nombre de changement d'avis de de
changement à 180 degrés montre quand
même soit de la préparation de
l'incompétence
en tout cas un gros paquet de nocivité
et c'est dans cet état de de confiance
sont rompues entre un gouvernement et
son peuple qu'on demande aux gens
d'accepter le pass sanitaire qui qui n'a
de sanitaires que le nom puisque on
n'aura pas le temps de rentrer dans les
détails mais cette mesure comme toutes
les précédentes
je vais redonner la parole justement
agent postal pour qu'il vous réponde sur
l'efficacité des vaccins par
l'efficacité des vaccins il faut pas
tordre le cou à la réalité scientifique
la réalité scientifique c'est que les
max un arn messagers ont une efficacité
95%
ça n'est pas 100% c'est vrai donc
efficacité de 95 % et c'est une
efficacité qui descend à 88% jeu contre
le variant delta donc on est d ambronay
en reste dans une dans une performance
maximale extrêmement élevés alors que
des personnes vaccinées puisse faire une
maladie qu vide
c'est vrai c'est vrai dans le cas
d'immunodépression importante
c'est exactement ce qu'on est en train
de vivre dans dans nos hôpitaux il ya
deux population hospitalisée n'est pas
six ans profondément immunodéprimés et
c'est normal parce que leur système
immunitaire répond très très mal à la
vaccination aux comme à n'importe quel
stimulation immunitaire et puis l'autre
l'autre population hospitalisée ce sont
les patients plus jeunes ils n'ont
vacciné et aulas a actuellement dans mon
chu on est en train d'organiser la
répartition des malades dans d'autres
services que la maladie infectieuse ce
qui est le signe absolument inéluctable
et pragmatique que la situation
recommence à empirer donc il ya un vrai
problème
30 à dire que l'allée des patients
vaccinés fondé des collines non non ça
c'est pas vrai le vaccin protège à 100%
contre les formes bras excepté excepté
je le redis chez les patients très
profondément immunodéprimées merci
beaucoup à vous jean paul stahl
infectiologues au chu de grenoble alpes
merci à vous également fabrice grimal
candidats citoyens élections
présidentielles on verra